except shortly okay I'm going to talk
about joint work with Dimitri Kosinski
McClure Center and swagger Tucson y'all
so actually swagger toe and the three of
us independently proved the lower bound
that I'm going to talk about so if you
go and look for this paper on the
archive you're actually gonna see two
papers but since we've merged the two
papers and we have a joint writer but we
haven't put it on the archive yet so it
should be there eventually okay so we're
gonna talk about function composition so
imagine you have two boolean functions G
can be a partial function and we look at
it I think a very natural operation
which is the composition of F and G okay
so we can take n strings x1 through xn
which are in the domain of G we evaluate
G on each of these n strings G of x1
through G of X n that gives us an N bit
string then we feed this in bit string
to F and look at the evaluation of F on
that ok so pictorially you know you can
kind of view it as as a two level
circuit here with the top gate is f the
bottom gates are G's the input to G are
these in bit strings here we feed those
into G and then feed the results in Jeff
so I think a very natural question for
people in this audience is how does the
complexity of F composed with G relate
to the individual complexities of F and
G and this is a question that you can
study for many many different complexity
measures so you know say where we have a
general complexity measure M kind of
what you expect from a complexity
measure is that it's sub multiplicative
okay so the complexity of F composed
with G is at most the complexity of F
times the complexity of G so it is true
for most complexity measures not all but
you know usually if this is true it's
not going to be difficult to prove
so the other direction on the
and which would be a lower bound on the
complexity of F compose G in terms of
the complexities of F and G that can you
know be quite difficult to prove and
that's what we refer to as a composition
theorem so there's you know many
composition theorems that have been
proven you know I decided to just select
a few from people who I thought would be
in the audience so so for example
approximate polynomial degree is a nice
example because it shows that even for
specific F and G so here if you just
want to know what is the approximate
polynomial degree of and composed with
or this can already be a very difficult
question okay so there was a long line
of work improving lower bounds on the
polynomial degree of n compose with or
until recently sure stuff and burnin
Taylor came up with a tight lower bound
and it's kind of what you expect right
it's the product of the approximate
degrees of the or in the end another one
you know since this is communication
complexity workshop I thought I'd
mentioned lifting theorems so you can
kind of also view this as a kind of
composition theorem although here the
setting is a little bit different
because you're composing two different
kinds of objects so here F is like a
query function G is a you know
communication gadget and what you try to
show is that the communication
complexity of F composed with G is at
least the query complexity of F times
the communication complexity of G this
has now been successfully done for quite
a few different kinds of communication
complexities and their associated Queen
measures so for example Goose pitocin
Watson I've done this for deterministic
and randomized communication
complexities so finally I want to point
out this work of Gilmer Saxena Vasa and
and tall who study composition for a lot
of different boolean function complexity
measures like certificate complexity
block sensitivity so block sensitivity
actually turns out to be one that
doesn't have this so
they're multiplicative property so
that's quite interesting okay so those
are some examples of you know different
kinds of composition theorems and the
literature we're going to focus on query
complexity okay so let me talk about
some composition theorems that are known
for query complexity so let's start off
with the deterministic case so it's very
easy to see that the deterministic
created complexity is sub multiplicative
right so if you want an algorithm for F
composed with G you just run an
algorithm for F whenever that F makes a
query then you go ahead and run an
algorithm for G in order to answer that
query and then you keep going like that
so Montanaro and tall in two different
papers showed that this is actually
tight okay so for deterministic created
complex you really have a perfect
composition theorem the complexity F
composed with G really is exactly the
product of the complexities of F and G
so for quantum query complexity we also
have a composition theorem this time
it's tight up to a multiplicative
constant factor I think it's actually
interesting actually the quantum case
was even proved before the Dermot
deterministic case but of the kind of
three main query complexities you know
deterministic quantum and randomized
randomized is the one that is still left
open okay so again the easy direction
holds you know with this extra extra log
factor but it's still open what the
lower bound is
look for the hard direction didn't you'd
want for all F and G
but again I mean you can also show it
for a specific F and G you know and like
the case of polynomial degree of and
composer or you know that can already be
interesting
okay so what's known about the lower
bound so been davido and Qatari show the
following lower bound so the randomize
complexity of F composed with G is at
least the randomized complexity of F
times the square root of the randomize
complexity of G and they show this for
any partial function f and total
function G so this square root is kind
of strange right it's not what you would
expect to to see there so we actually
show an example where F is a relation so
we allow you know something more general
and G is a partial function where in
fact the square root is needed okay so
we give an example of a relation F and a
partial function G such that the
randomized complexity of F composed with
G really is at most the randomized
complexity of F times the square root of
the randomized complexity of G and we
show that this is tight even in this
more general situation right where F can
be a relation and G is a partial
function okay so let me make a couple
remarks at this stage so you might
wonder why am i carrying around these
different error bounds so once you go
and talk about relations then you know
it's not obvious that you can always
amplify the success probability right
you can't just do the thing of you know
repeat the algorithm several times and
take a majority vote because with the
relation your algorithm could be
outputting a different correct answer
you know every time so so we have to
carry around these error bounds and also
really I think the important thing for
the lower bound is that G is a partial
function okay so that's really the
interesting thing for the lower bound I
think that you know Rob initially they
weren't interested in relations but
probably their their proof could carry
through for relay
but the bottleneck for them would be the
fact that G is total okay so kind of I
think the innovation and our lower bound
is that you know it works for these
partial functions G okay so I'm gonna
describe this example so I think this I
can I can fully describe the example and
hopefully this is something that you can
really onboard into your brain the lower
bound I'm just going to talk about at a
very high level okay so let's first talk
about the example
okay so f is a relation it's a subset of
its pairs of n bit strings and it's
defined in the following way so in the
relation our pairs of strings X comma a
where the Hamming distance between X and
ay is at most n over 2 minus square root
of n again again what what is the setup
here you know X is the unknown string
we're making queries to X and the
question is how many queries do we have
to make to X in order to output some and
bit string a such that a and X are close
that they agree and at least in over 2
plus root n positions
okay so the randomized query complexity
of this relation is like rudin okay so
basically you know for the upper bound
you can just query the first you know
whatever a hundred times root in bits of
X and then randomly complete that you
know just randomly choose zero one to
complete that to a in bit string a and
you know with decent probability you'll
be correct for the lower bound so for
the lower bound we can use what Joshua
also mentioned this minimax theorem so
randomized query complexity is
equivalent to looking at the
deterministic distributional complexity
so just think about a deterministic
algorithm which is computing this
relation under the uniform distribution
and say that you only make you know root
n over ten many queries right so now
this algorithm is going to partition the
input space into sub cubes right sub
cubes are basically sets of strings that
are consistent with some 0 1 star
assignment ok so now just imagine a sub
cube you know say a sub cube where the
first root in over ten bits you know are
fixed to be 0 and the rest of the bits
can be whatever you want now if you look
at a sub cube that is you know this
large right I mean there's like two to
the N minus 0.1 root in many strings in
the sub cube there's basically no good a
that you can out output on the sub-q --b
right any a that your output is going to
be wrong on more than half of the
strings in the sub cube okay so that's
basically how you show a lower bound of
Omega root n as well okay so this is the
outer relation F now let's talk about
the the inner function G okay so look
here first so G of X is going to be a
partial function you should output zero
if the Hamming weight of the input is
less than n over 2 minus root N and
output 1 if the hemming rate is more
than n over 2
plus reading okay and we claim that the
complexity of this G is Theta of n okay
so the lower bound is actually taken
care of for us again by a connection to
communication complexity okay so the gap
hamming distance communication problem
right is the poem where Alice has X Bob
has Y and the question is is the Hamming
distance between x and y bigger than n
over 2 plus root N or less than n over 2
minus root n so you can see that that
function is actually just our G here of
the sore of x and y ok so now
Chakrabarti and rhaegar have showed that
the communication complexity of this
function is omega n so that means that
the query complexity of G also has to be
Omega n right if it wasn't then that
would give you a communication algorithm
to compute the gap Hamming problem ok so
this lower bound follows pretty easily
from this communication complexity
result yeah
simultaneous no I mean because the
algorithm for G can be adaptive right in
the query model so that could lead to an
adaptive communication protocol yeah
okay so now we're going to get so that's
F and G now we're going to get into the
protocol for F composed with G so before
that let's just make you know one
observation about G and that's that
although to compute G with bounded error
it requires like in many queries if you
only want to compute G with a slight
advantage over 1/2 like say advantage
you know 10 over root n you can actually
do that with just a constant number of
queries and the reason for that is that
you know just query one random bit of
the input that's already correlated with
the with G of X right with a function
value so if we just sample like a
hundred bits at random of the input you
know we can boost this success
probability to say have advantage you
know something like 10 over root n over
random guessing okay so that's gonna be
very important for for our example ok
we're kind of playing with with the with
the error
ok so although G is hard with bounded
error you know if you only want you know
like advantage something 1 over root n
over over random guessing you can do
that with just constant constant many
queries
okay so here's our protocol so again
what's our goal so we're given so
there's some input x1 through xn that
we're making queries to and our goal is
to produce something close and having
distance to G of x1 through g of xn okay
so what are we gonna do okay so for each
i from 1 to n we're going to query a
hundred random bits of x i we're going
to take the majority and we're gonna set
AI equal to that and and now then we're
gonna output that a ok so with
probability you know something like 1/2
plus 10 over root in each AI is going to
agree with g of x i okay so therefore if
we look at this string a as a whole with
high probability it's going to agree
with X and at least n over 2 plus root
in many positions ok does that does that
make sense
okay so that's the protocol so how many
queries
did we make well we just made order in
many queries right we made like a
hundred queries and to each X I okay so
we made like order of n many queries on
the other hand you know the complexity
of the outer relation F is root n the
complexity of G is n so kind of the
naive composition would give you into
the three halves okay so for this
problem this bound write complexity of F
times square root of complexity of G is
is actually tight okay and I think it's
important to note again how we played
with the error here right so kind of the
naive algorithm would just be to you
know choose root in many positions and
spent in many queries into those X to
get bounded error but we played with the
fact that actually if you you know only
want very small advantage over random
guessing then this G has you know a very
easy proto
all right just constant many queries so
yeah wise words I mean the you explained
it early on but I don't see where we're
well actually came into yeah I mean here
it's to be honest for this particular
relation it's it's irrelevant because
this relation you can amplify success
probability right so yeah I could say
one third one third I mean yeah I mean
in the upper bound I could get our of
one third if I wanted to right but so
but for a general F relation you know I
don't know how our 4/9 relates to our
one third for this particular F yeah
they're basically the same thing because
this F I can amplify what is that make
sense in which the 4/9
as opposed to 1217
well basically okay let me let me get
back to that in just a second when we
talk about the lower bound then didn't
member see you had a question
could you see I don't have the intuition
to so it seems almost a coincidence that
these upper and lower bounds are just
matched each other do you have intuition
of why I like this should be the right
answer and are there other relations and
other partial functions F and G where
the bounds are tight let's see I mean
maybe also that I will I will defer to
once we see something about the lower
bound I mean you can kind of see why
like here right I mean you for these
particular numbers right root N and n
you know I could have maybe written
something else here that also multiplies
it in right but I think when you look at
the lower bound maybe you'll see why
this comes out you used an algorithm for
F instead of square root n which is a
bit surprising I guess
because you have a random assignment for
this growth in that you yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah right yeah sure sure I
mean you kind of have to play with this
right I mean youyou can't just do the
naive kind of composition because that
will give you the naive bound right so
you kind of have to do something else
okay all right so let me say something
about the lower bound okay so we
actually think about the lower bound
again as an upper bound as designing an
algorithm okay so we basically start off
with the protocol for F composed with G
and we use this protocol in order to
give the to give a protocol for F okay
so you know it's always nice when you
can turn the lower bound into like an
upper bound and the basic idea is of
course we cannot make a query every time
our algorithm for F composed with G
makes it query right that would be way
too many queries so we somehow need to
to save on on queries and you know the
key thing is going to be kind of
counting what this factor is you know by
what factor of queries we save okay so
the proof of Shalev and and Robin you
know it kind of follows the same
framework and kind of the difference
between our proof and that proof is what
complexity measure we use here okay okay
so the high level idea is say that we
want to compute F of Z so Z is an N bit
string here and we want to use our
protocol for F composed with G to do
this so what are we going to do
well we're going to sample x1 through xn
where G of X I is equal to Z I so what
that basically means is that any
anything any output that PI produces on
x1 through xn is actually going to be a
good output for F on Z okay
okay so that's the basic idea of course
the problem with this is how are you
going to sample X I write because to
sample X I such that G of X I equals Z I
well you have to know what Zi is okay
and that's gonna cost you
queries okay so okay so let me just
describe this in a little bit more more
detail with a picture so imagine that
this is a deterministic tree for F
composed with G so again in designing
our algorithm we're going to use you
know the minimax theorem and and design
a deterministic algorithm that works for
for a particular distribution okay so
imagine that this is our tree you know
this is the top part of our tree and
what I want you to think about is kind
of the probabilities of going left and
right under the following process so we
fix some Z and 0 1 to the N and we also
fix distributions mu 0 and mu 1 over you
know G inverse of 0 and G inverse of 1
now imagine this process where I sample
X I according to mu Z I and I basically
look at the probability over paths
induced in this tree right so at the
root I have some probability of going
left some probability going right here I
have some probability going left some
probability going right excetera okay so
basically what we want to do is we want
to simulate this distribution by making
as few queries as possible ok all right
so maybe how you can do this will be
more clear here so let's just focus on
this very first query right the top
query and now say if G of X 1 is drawn
from mu 0 maybe the probability that X 1
3 is 0 is some number p 0 okay if X 1 is
drawn from u 1 right G of X 1 equals 1
the probability that X 1 3 is 0 could be
something else right it could be p 1
okay and now I want to simulate this
query which basically means I want to go
right with probability P zero if I'm in
this case and I want to go right with
probability P one if I'm in this case
okay and I want to do this by you know
just making some fractional query right
with very low probability I want to have
to actually make it query okay so how
can I do that well imagine that p 0 is
less than P 1 and I'm just going to
randomly choose R and 0 1 in this
interval okay so if R is actually less
than P 0 then I can just go left right
if R is bigger than P 1 I can just go
right right because I should go right
and in both of these cases so actually
the only time I have to query is if R is
in in between p0 and p1 okay so if our
lands in between p0 and p1 then I have
to actually query okay what is Z 1 and
then once I know what Z 1 is then I know
you know whether I should go left or go
right ok so this is kind of the the
fundamental procedure that we use in
designing our protocol for F at this
procedure that we call the the bit
sampler so you see that in this case
right we're not always having to query
z1 right we're going to do it with some
probability and this be the key to you
know computing how many queries we save
in this process is to you know estimate
well how often is it that you know we're
going to land in between p0 and p1 ok so
to do this we define a complexity
measure which we call the conflict
complexity okay so the complete this
measure is basically you know exactly
what I just described so we we have some
distributions mu 0 mu 1 we have a tree
that computes G and we run this bit
sampler routine and the question is
where's the expected number of times
that I can run this bit sampler routine
before I have to actually make
query okay and now as usual I'm gonna
maximize over distributions I minimize
over trees and that's what we call the
conflict complexity so now kind of
intuitively you know what you expect is
that when I'm running this algorithm for
F composed with G you know how many
times have I actually going to have to
query well I'm actually only going to
have to query you know for every Coyote
queries I make I'm only gonna have to
really make a real query once okay so
that's kind of the the intuition and
this is this is what we're able to show
okay so now to finish the proof we
actually show that conflict complexity
is quadratically tight even for partial
G so there's there's a randomized
algorithm for G with complexity at most
this conflict complexity squared oh yeah
yeah this should be a little G yeah okay
this is kind of the difference with you
know with the measure that we use in the
measure that's used by Shalev and Robin
their measure is called Savatage
complexity and therefore sabotage
complexity was actually unbounded
separations for partial G whoa I mean I
guess using conflict you know allows you
to send it to extend to to partial
partial G I actually I don't know the
relationship between conflict and
sabotage like you know which one is
greater but they're both quadratically
tight so yeah yeah okay they're both
exactly type for total functions yeah so
the conflict is is also tight for
quadratic type for partial functions
yeah okay so I guess I'm out of time so
I'll finish up
you know the main open question still
remains right so you know say for total
functions F and G you know what should
be the the lower bound for for
randomized composition okay I'll finish
there Thanks
I didn't answer your question yeah go
ahead no now I understood so though okay
my you had 4/9 was it was motivated by
the other by the lower oh yeah yes sure
sure yeah okay okay yeah yeah yeah so
your example though you guys uses
relations yeah yeah so it's still need
an open for partial functions that's
right yeah it would even be open for say
F yeah a function and G a partial
function yeah yeah yeah so this is sort
of suggested and profound like in the
randomized case for relations and
partial functions is the composition
theorem only for total functions oh no I
think that also works for partial in the
partial functions yeah I think there's a
paper of Shelby Kimmel that does that
Jenna's Asian yeah relations actually I
don't know if if then you want to study
in quantum well
yeah in the search problem it's a very
sort of large domain yeah he's that sort
of I mean it's obvious in the example
right yeah I don't know I mean yes I
mean certainly you know as a step
towards going to the outer function the
outer problem actually being a function
yeah I mean one thing you could think of
would be to you know reduce you know the
the size yeah but I don't know
unfortunately no so it it really is this
yeah basically fixed distribution mu 0
mu 1 you have a tree which which
actually computes G and then basically
you run this bit simpler procedure on
this tree and you look at the expected
number of queries you have to to make
before you know you throw an R which
lands in between that p0 and p1
there was something else oh there was
the distribution of a freeze which you
obviously get to minimize over yes so
just like normal distribution of
complexity you maximize over
distribution you minimize over
algorithms right actually the quantum
case just behaves so nicely so the
reason is because in the quantum case we
have this lower bound technique the
adversary method and this method you
know it's like you can write it as an
SDP so it's kind of a you know nice
object and it just characterizes quantum
query complexity even for partial
functions and so this that's right carts
result and so and you can show that this
SDP perfectly composes you know and kind
of the the natural thing right for one
direction you take solutions to the
primal you compose them for the other
direction you take solutions to the dual
you compose them so so that's why you
know randomized we don't have a nice
lower bound technique which we know that
characterizes or randomized query
complexity right that we could kind of
use in the same way
yes another traditional version of this
collective JJ applied the minimax you
might expect to get something left at
this point
wait say gimme what haha okay so you
apply minimax when you get into the
gibberish I got ya where's basement
oh so what is the worst-case version of
conflict yeah I don't know yeah I don't
know right and also for things like
recursive majority of three right the
complexity is still open so yeah but
then at least we're crystal more Guardi
yeah sure would seem to show that I mean
there are functions where you don't get
a perfect right right yeah yeah yeah
composition they talk though what's it
you mean like that don't they
well I'm just thinking just take
majority in two-level majority like
right so that's the composition of
majority with itself and I think that
it's going to show that because there is
an advantage you get over yeah but it's
just like a constant factor right I
think you have to be careful right when
you talk about these things that are
composed many times because you could
sell have a composition theorem that's
just off by a constant factor right but
once you iterate that D times and
yeah so that's kind of my other open
question so to be honest we didn't
really look into any of these things so
we just kind of used conflict complexity
for this one application so actually I
don't know how it fits in the pantheon
of complexity measures
okay
[Applause]